we've been for the last few weeks on
Saturdays taking a look at the history
of US intelligence and
counterintelligence joining us now from
Boston is Peter gross he is the author
of gentleman spy he also wrote this book
operation rollback America's secret war
behind the or Iron Curtain and he joins
us today to talk about the life and
influence of Allen Dulles good morning
sir good morning good morning whatever
time of day it is wherever you are
our first question is what was Allen
Dulles contribution or biggest
contribution to the US intelligence
service well Allen Dulles is surely one
of the most enigmatic and conflicted
personalities of the American 20th
century he was as the biography I wrote
calls him very much a gentleman a 19th
century figure yet he was the
inspiration of an American intelligence
establishment a an arm of government
which was officially sanctioned to do
things which could not be officially
acknowledged he was not the first he was
not the founder of the CIA but he was
its
inspiration and longtime director and
how directly did he inspire it as you
say Allen Dulles started life as a
diplomat but he had he was intrigued by
the things that could be done under the
guise of diplomacy to influence to
promote to encourage trends in foreign
policy secretly he believed that not
everything had to be out in the open and
that often things could be done much
more usefully without public
acknowledgement this was a if we take
this kind of for granted today but at
the in the 1940s 50 years ago 60 years
ago it was not at all taken for granted
it was a radical notion with effects
that some would say have been bit
and others probably many more would say
have been destructive to the American
role of through the 20th century we can
argue about that
well old was Allen Dulles when he became
director of the CIA how how old was he
he was in early middle age he was born
in 1893 so he would have been in his 50s
already a distinguished public figure in
in government in the law the wall street
law he was he was a renowned commentator
and thinker on American foreign policy
he also of although we didn't know it at
the time he also was one of the most
successful American intelligence
operators during World War two in
penetrating Nazi Germany through his net
the network of agents which he set up
from his base in neutral Switzerland we
learned about that after the war
obviously we didn't know it during the
war he was a true professional in the
game of intelligence intelligence
operations at a time when there weren't
any professionals except for him and we
are going to be talking about Allen
Dulles as we continue our look at the
history of US intelligence if you'd like
to chime in and offer some comments and
ask Peter Gross a question about Allen
Dulles you can call on one of four lines
on your screen 202 five eight five three
eight eight zero four Republicans - OH -
five eight five three eight eight one
for Democrats and for all others - OH -
five eight five three eight eight - we
also have a special line set aside for
members of the intelligence community
it's two oh two five eight five three
eight eight three at the beginning of
his intelligence career what was Allen
Dulles his first mission as a young
diplomat his first assignment was to the
United States Embassy in Vienna in 1916
World War one was going on he was the
junior third secretary and shortly after
he arrived this is what makes him such a
colorful figure shortly after he arrived
the Habsburg Emperor Franz Joseph died
and here was this young diplomat who
represented the United States at the
funeral of the great Habsburg Emperor
that was his first mission that's how
his career began that's the book end at
the beginning the funeral of the Emperor
Franz Joseph the other book end at the
end of his career you haven't asked me
this yet but it completes the picture of
Allan Dulles he served on the Warren
Commission investigating the
assassination of John F Kennedy from the
Emperor Franz Joseph to John F Kennedy
that was the career of Allen Dulles and
how long did he serve as CIA director he
was CIA director through most of
throughout the Eisenhower administration
and into the first year of the Kennedy
administration he was DCI from 1953 to
1961 a very long time for a head of
Central Intelligence our first question
this morning is on our line for
Democrats
good morning go ahead are you there yeah
what's your question for mr. gross sir
uh mr. gross I'm just curious as to why
after a spy is caught an American spy is
caught why is he after he's debriefed
why why do we keep him alive
they cost Americans so many problems I
was just curious as to why they're not
shot like they are in Russia I'm sorry I
you mean when the United States captures
a spy a person who's been caught in
espionage why they're not shot right
away if the the issue is the United
States is not the Soviet Union and we do
have the rule of law and in espionage
cases it's never as clear-cut as you
make it sound the United States has
executed spies starting I mean we can go
back to the to the story of Nathan Hale
who wasn't it was he wasn't spying for
the United States but
there have been executions but there
have also been legal procedures and
frequently you say after they've been
debriefed frequently the debriefing has
to go on for many many years because the
the Espionage agent can continue to
supply interesting tidbits and useful
information a member of the intelligence
community is next from Vienna Virginia
go ahead please yes I'm a former Marine
signal intelligence analyst and I was in
a radiator reconnaissance unit and in
Hawaii and we used to deploy into the
South Pacific gym and do things down
there and I was just wondering the
intelligence community in general do
they go about recruiting spies from the
military units or do they get them to
the civilian world mostly how does that
work well first of all they don't
recruit spies the spy is a very loose
word covering a multitude of sins or
virtues depending on where you are the
preferred word is agents undercover
agents agents serving under diplomatic
business educational cover careers
recruitment by the CIA is done not only
in the military services in fact rather
less likely in the military services
because the military has its own
intelligence branches and missions which
are quite often quite different from the
CIA they're recruited among the
population at large among young people
men and women who are interested in some
kind of public service who don't know
probably when they go into the agency
whether they're going to be a public
overt analyst or whether they're going
to operate under some kind of cover
which takes many years to build up you
don't apply for a job as a spy and and
you'll find yourself acting as an
undercover agent only after a long
period of preparation when mr. Dulles
became
head of the CIA what are some of the
first things he did to establish his own
tone in the department what are the
things that he saw that maybe needed to
to be improved on well even before he
became head of the CIA he strongly
influenced this new novel organization
for for secret intelligence he knew how
to set up networks of agents the the the
complicated filigree of contacts and
missions many of which individually
seemed petty but when put together by
the man at the top it was only men at
the top in those days add up to a
picture of information secretly acquired
which can be of use to policymakers
Allen Dulles knew how to do this he was
one of the few American public figures
or private figures who knew how to do
this and so he had a strong influence on
the procedures for acquiring secret
information that's how that remember the
United States was still smarting under
the surprise attack at Pearl Harbor and
we are the the national leadership
democrat-republican whatever didn't want
to be caught red-handed like that again
so how do you avoid that kind of
surprise attack well you you find ways
of getting information and who knew
better than Allen Dulles how to do that
our next call is on our line for others
from Somerset New Jersey good morning
good morning go ahead Lisa thank you uh
yes sir I heard you mention that mr.
Dulles served as the Eisenhower
administration being somewhat of a
person into history
I believe dodges Howard ministered
during the Eisenhower administration the
CIA was one of the most embarrassing
things America had to offer considering
what he did to Fidel Castro who was
quoting Thomas Jefferson to mr. Dalton
CIA thought about invading Cuba and
tried to do it and twist Castro to
Russia
I believe you're involved in the
Philippines where a Democratic leader
like the president was overthrown that
country is still smarting
from that effort to this day and I also
believe the CIA had a lot to do with
purchase the moment we know that country
is still smarting and still on his knees
as a result of someone that you gave me
a whole lot of accolades to it I just
don't see where he deserves it that's a
very fair commentary the and by
accolades I'm I'm talking about him as a
professional of intelligence under his
leadership the United States government
suffered many embarrassments the one
perhaps most striking which you did not
mention was the the shooting down of a
u-2 spy plane which President Eisenhower
stood up before the world and denied a
few days later the president the United
States was shown and revealed in an
outright lie this was the fault of the
CIA this was under Allen Dulles
leadership the you could have mentioned
the CIA operations in Iran in 1953 the
overthrow of Mossad deck with
implications that we still are suffering
through the an attempted coup in
Guatemala in 1954 throwing out the
legally elected President our bins again
the implications of CIA meddling in
third world countries still continues
the Bay of Pigs operations not under
Eisenhower instantly but under John
Kennedy was definitely on the watch of
Allen Dulles and he was stepped down
shortly thereafter it was an American
disaster it was an American it was a CIA
disaster the record is by no means pure
and clean how was he perceived as a
leader the the most the hardest thing
when I was writing his biography the
hardest thing about Allen Dulles was to
convey the complex nature of his
character and his personality enigmatic
secretive in
what he was doing he was one of the most
colorful and genial uh people of his
time
remember Allen Dulles was the younger
brother there was the older brother John
Foster Dulles who was much more famous a
towering stature in his day he was the
secretary of state all-powerful
secretary of state for eisenhower he was
a very austere and a distant figure not
particularly beloved by the public at
large Allen Dulles the younger brother
he was cheerful genial always ready with
quips and colorful comments one of the
people who I had discussed his biography
with as I was writing it summed up the
two brothers John Foster Dulles many
people who agreed with him still didn't
like him Allen Dulles most people who
didn't agree with him could not help but
like him so as a leader there is no
doubt that he generated immense loyalty
which still exists within the
intelligence community a member of the
intelligence community calling him from
Quaker pen Quakertown Pennsylvania good
morning
good morning go ahead hello sorry you
there go ahead we've lost him
hello hello go ahead Denver Colorado is
next on our line for Republicans good
morning good morning go ahead I look
forward to purchasing mr. grouses book
today as a matter of fact it sounds very
interesting let me just ask him a few
questions I realize a good spy like a
wise internist doesn't ever tell all he
knows
but I thought Vienna was the spy capital
of the world or is that just a throwback
to the Second World War and secondly
since I have you on the line it wouldn't
it be nice if the intelligence community
community could figure some way of
identifying
ours the stolen cars taken of course
this is a detail that probably most
people aren't terribly interested in but
so that the car could be identified as
across the border back into Mexico when
they were when they were stolen and that
could be a satellite project but anyway
I look forward to hearing your
discussion and thanks very much well
thank you for those comments they're
probably a lot of cities around the
world which would vie for the title of
spy capital of the world either vie for
it or run away from it Lisbon Sweden
Bern Switzerland Berlin as the as world
politics have changed so have the the
places where intelligence agents meet
and do their dirty tricks you know the
the the techniques of acquiring
information change with with the times
with the sorts of information that are
required some things now can be done by
electronic eavesdropping by satellite
photographs or other sensing devices
there's still a lot of things however
the intentions of people which cannot be
discerned electronically and it is
necessary to have human contacts the the
the human agent which is what Allen
Dulles knew in World War two remains a
vital figure in intelligence
st. Thomas Virgin Island is next go
ahead please yes good morning to you
into your guests I attended that
Pennsylvania State University in the mid
50's before Allen Dulles became director
of CIA was he not in a position of
leadership president at the University
there or had some association with the
Pennsylvania State University in the 50s
mr. gross hello excuse me yes are you
there yes I'm here yet his career was
never in
D Mia he was a Wall Street lawyer he was
a partner in the firm of Sullivan &
Cromwell after he stopped after he
resigned from the American Foreign
Service he was a pillar of the American
legal establishment and a leader of the
Council on Foreign Relations he did not
have any academic career though he was
widely respected in academic circles
when he took head of the CIA you talked
about some of the low points of the the
organization under his leadership what
were some of the high points you know
anything I say I'm going to be jumped on
because what one man's high point is
another man's low point I think it would
have to be said that the the lasting
legacy of Allen Dulles beyond any
specific operation was the creation of a
responsible more or less depending on
the time and the circumstances
government agency where none existed
before a an organization responsible to
the political leadership it never went
it never went off on its own like a
rogue elephant for very long there were
individual cases and they were promptly
dealt with the notion of the CIA as a
secret government or as a rogue elephant
really is not borne out by by the
histories that we can now see as
documents are released the political
leadership first Harry Truman and the
Truman administration where it all got
started remembered then Eisenhower and
his administration Kennedy etc etc the
political leadership has always called
the tune for what the agency would do
if sometimes enthusiasts within the
agency tried to get away with something
as they did they were dealt with with
relative promptness
I think Allen Dulles has to be given the
credit for establishing that tradition
of responsible relatively competent
actions and mechanisms to carry out
government policy Glenn Allen Virginia
on our line for Republicans good morning
go ahead please yes thank you when I
went to school there were a bunch of
Hungarian freedom fighters there too and
they were promised by the CIA that they
would get support and their fight
against the Soviet Union when the rider
tried to retake hungry they were
shooting machine guns off the roads and
things like that obviously it went down
quite sour and they were lucky to escape
with their lives thank you
this 1956 episode is certainly one of
the most controversial and troubling
episodes in American intelligence
history it is not as clear-cut as you
just described it or indeed as Hungarian
freedom fighters perceived it the
documentary evidence is clear that the
United States government did not promise
military or other military or that kind
of political support to this rebellion
enthusiasts in the field who were radio
announcers and who were suddenly given
microphones and were able to talk
without discipline may indeed have given
the perception that American tanks were
waiting to come in which was never true
many inquiries took place by several
different governments including the the
German government where these radio
stations were
located these enquiries took place after
the the the the 1956 uprising and the
although the CIA admitted lacks
discipline among some of its outlying
spokespeople announcers usually
emigrates themselves from Hungary the
record is clear that the CIA did not
instigate or promise to promote this
uprising this was a heroic uprising of
Hungarian people themselves frankly at
that time perhaps even now the CIA does
not have the competence to run that kind
of show this was a Hungarian operation
of which modern day Hungary should be
very proud Inglewood California on our
line for others good morning go ahead
yeah good morning thanks for c-span's
I'm curious you you were talking about
about how he yeah where did he get his
training where did he get his ideas for
for becoming a spy you implied that he
just knew it he had a now training who
were his heroes this is a this is a
really good question because remember
Allen Dulles younger son of a doer
Presbyterian minister in upstate New
York a diplomat in the family tradition
his father was a minister but his uncle
was a diplomat Secretary of State for
President Wilson the diplomatic service
seemed the right thing for him to do and
he was interested in people in
mixing with people that was always his
his special talent how did he learn
there was no one to teach him in World
War one intelligence was such a
primitive operation and no one knew how
to do it
Dulles picked it up talk about
on-the-job training
there's one you know anecdotes incidents
taught him lessons and one of the most
famous if I can have a couple minutes
because this is one of the most famous
Allen Dulles stories there he was a
young diplomat by this time he was in
Bern Switzerland 1917 and he was the
junior it was Easter Sunday he was the
junior man on the staff
so when a caller an unknown caller
called in to the embassy he was the one
who had to take the call a heavy foreign
voice said I must speak to someone of
the United States Embassy right away it
was Sunday Dulles wanted to play tennis
with a girlfriend she said no no no I'm
sorry the Embassy is closed we're not
available
The Voice insisted no no it is important
that we speak I won't try to imitate the
foreign accent and Dulles said well if
it's so important I'll come in on Monday
when the embassy will be open and the
voice said no no Monday is too late it's
too late and the Dulles hung up the
phone never pursued it on Monday the
caller whose name was vladimir Ilyich
Lenin got on a train and went to
Petrograd
to begin the Bolshevik Revolution and
because of his girlfriend and his tennis
game Allen Dulles had muffed the
opportunity for a face-to-face talk with
Lenin Dulles would tell this story about
himself many times especially to new
recruits into the agency with the lesson
which he learned you asked how did he
learn to do these things he learned
always be available to people do not
slam the door on anyone because you
never know who is going to be useful or
interesting or valuable for what you are
trying to achieve that's one of the
lessons
New York City on our line for Democrats
hello go ahead two questions one is have
you read the book the second oldest
profession by Philip Knightley yes
indeed I take away from that book that
the whole enterprise of spying is a
complete waste of time and money because
the whole system is fatally flawed in
the sense that there is no way that any
outsider has of telling whether they're
getting information which is useful or
not and another example of the fatally
flawed nature of the system is the fact
that every time they make a mistake they
always argue because it's because they
didn't have enough in the way of
resources so it basically the worse they
are the more resources they're able to
garner and certainly the kinds of things
you've been talking about so far this
morning are much more along the lines of
their failures than successes so I'd
like to I'd like you to discuss a little
bit about why you think spying is useful
at all my second question is with regard
to Kim Roosevelt's retrospective book on
the Mossadegh overthrow in 1953 in Iran
which I believe was written in the early
1980s I've also recently read that it
strikes me that there is a complete lack
of insight and any kind of learning
experience that went on in that book
between the time of the overthrow in
1953 and the time the book was written
several decades later thank you I think
it is a vast overstatement to say that
espionage is fatally flawed espionage is
intelligence gathering is not a science
it is an art there are mistakes made it
isn't perfect but that is a great jump
from saying it's fatally flawed the
acquisition of secret intelligence
cannot be 100% accurate and there will
be mistakes there are mistakes they are
widely known that doesn't mean however
it is
not worth the effort there have been
successes there have been American
agents placed in critical positions
inside the Kremlin inside the Soviet
government the United States
policymakers learned a great deal about
Soviet military and nuclear capabilities
from human agents which they would not
have known had there been no organized
intelligence service incidentally there
I have to tell you the a wonderful
impish French of course intelligence
chief once strongly criticized to me the
notion of intelligence as the second
oldest profession he said it is the
first oldest profession because before
you can go to the place for the other
thing you have to know the address and
the telephone number only the French
could come up with that analysis as for
Kim Roosevelt's views and his learning
experiences I can say let me say two
things that Spy memoirs intelligence
memoirs are like other memoirs of public
and private figures notoriously
selective in what they say in how they
people remember things exactly the way
they want to remember things so none of
these memoirs can be taken as a factual
gospel I do think there is a learning
experience that Kim Roosevelt however
went through and it it happened very
quickly
Kim Roosevelt was one of åland Alice's
leading undercover operatives
and indeed he was the key covert agent
who engineered the overthrow of
Mossadegh in Iran in 1953 a year later
when the CIA when Dulles and the
Eisenhower administration wanted to
overthrow our bins in Guatemala half a
world away
Dulles turned to Kim Roosevelt and said
hey can can you pull the same thing
and Roosevelt flatly refused saying
Guatemala is not Iran The Situation's
are completely different you cannot run
the kind of operation in Guatemala that
we ran in Iran and no I won't do it
turned him down flatly so other people
were given the job so I do think we have
to give some people credit Allen Dulles
on down for learning from their
experience we were talking with Peter
Gross he is the author of several books
including gentleman's by the life of
åland Dulles a couple of weeks ago we
talked about the head of the OSS William
Donovan described the relationship
between Donovan and Dulles Donovan was
Dulles first boss so to speak in
intelligence in in civilian intelligence
and it was Donovan who hired Dulles
Dulles worked for him loyally throughout
the war it quickly became apparent
however that Dulles knew a great deal
more about how to manage intelligence
then Donovan did Donovan knew a lot
about bureaucratic politics which Dulles
wasn't very good at Donovan knew how to
maneuver and my goodness did he ever
have to maneuver between conflicting
interests in Washington between military
civilian political personnel personality
you you went into all that Dulles was
very bad on bureaucratic infighting but
as I said before he was such a genial
figure that it was very hard for even
his enemies in the military intelligence
services to to stay angry with him for
very long after the war Donovan was
unceremoniously how stood by Harry
Truman the OSS was abolished and but a
few years later when Truman realized
that he'd made a mistake and that we
needed an intelligence service
he turned more to Dulles than he did to
Donovan
grunting Dulles was younger and and also
he recognized the talent Donovan
probably looked upon Allen Dulles as an
ingrate and Donovan probably wanted to
be the head of the new CIA but it was
not to be so in the last year's the the
mentor and protege relationship had had
frayed Albuquerque New Mexico up next on
our line for Republicans go good morning
go ahead good morning good morning mr.
gross I have two questions for you
they're kind of like little tidbits if
you will the first question is do agents
in some separate company account
companies countries know each other and
the reason I asked that question is that
of course that everything will go
nameless but I have a friend that I
talked to that was a foreign agent
overseas and there was a Russian agent
whose children was very very ill and
they didn't have the pharmaceuticals in
Russia and our agent so he told me and
this is the only story I ever got out of
him he wouldn't tell me anything else
our agent action whose cover was in the
pharmaceutical industry got the Russian
agent the medication necessary to save
his child's life so that the the James
Bond cloak-and-dagger guys going around
shooting each other
certainly is is not that images as far
as that story is concerned and the
second question is how did you go about
researching your book to get all the
information that you know you had to get
to to publish it that's a very nice
story which I had not heard before but
it is completely believable it's one of
the ironies yes there is kind of a
comradeship among agents not all of them
of course agents of friendly and enemy
powers sometimes do know each other they
may not know exactly who the other
person is or well they certainly won't
know exactly what the other person's
mission is
but they share common tensions pressures
demands and in rare cases it might be
that there would be that kind of
comradeship and I like that story very
much researching the book of allan
dulles and the the later book on
operation rollback was a challenge
because the Freedom of Information Act
goes only so far when you're dealing
with secret intelligence diplomatic
archives may be largely opened but
intelligence archives are very heavily
censored in some cases in most cases
frankly operational documents are
destroyed only two or three two years
later not because any they might have
some political significance but just in
the normal routine they're shredded so
the files are not complete a lot of
allan dulles career was outside
intelligence and that was a fascinating
to to talk with members of his family
and his associates and i actually I met
I did meet Allen Dulles I was a
schoolboy at the time and he was the
director of Central Intelligence so it
was hardly a a fruitful interview but
there were plenty of other people around
who could share their memories of him
when it comes to the actual political
and intelligence operations it was a
process of triangulation you had the
memories of of retired agents like Kim
Roosevelt and other people which were
sometimes reliable sometimes not
reliable you had memories of other
people that you could match with that
you had policy documents some of them
from the State Department more
interesting from the National Security
Council from the White House itself you
could piece these things together and I
made the rule with that as I was
researching the book that that I would
report any incident any episode which
came from only one source this is a
fairly standard rule of journalists and
it should be of historians there had to
be more than one source and frequently
to my sorrow even now there were some
episodes that I just could not put in
the book because I could not confirm
them to that level of reliability this
is the cover of the book gentleman by
the life of Allen Dulles he is also
written operation rolled back America's
secret war behind the Iron Curtain was
mr. Dulles married oh yes married
married just once to a very gracious
lady named clover who had absolutely
nothing to do with the intelligence side
of his life it has to be said Dulles was
a very convivial and charming
philanderer he also had several
mistresses who were known to his wife
and in at least one case wife and
mistress became closest lifelong friends
this was a kind of interesting Edwardian
side to Allen Dulles character Mary bran
Croft is the mistress Ranieri Bancroft
is one of them and she is the one who
became clover Dallas's lifelong friend
this was during World War Two clover was
in New York at home Allen was in the
field in Switzerland and Mary Bancroft
was his very gung-ho very able kind of
assistant who they would work together
on running their intelligence networks
and they worked very well together
Atlanta Georgia on our line for others
good morning go ahead please Atlanta are
you there yes sir good morning I had my
question answered about the OSS earlier
but I still would like to ask what was
the principal area and of research and
in what librarian and what government
agencies did dr. gross do his work
hang up and listen thank you all over
the place
Dulles his own personal papers are at
Princeton along with his brothers John
Foster Allen Dulles his personal papers
are very interesting letters of the busy
man but absolutely nothing about
intelligence he quite properly did not
take any of his office files home
the CIA itself provided a significant
amount of information in declassified
documents and in subsequent analyses
which they were which were written
in-house and of course carefully
classified but they were willing to
declassify them for me with all sorts of
deletions some of which were so silly
and petty that it was easy to understand
what was behind the black marks you
didn't need any great skill in
cryptography to figure out what they
were saying
the State Department as I said the
Eisenhower library and the records of
the National Security Council were
particularly valuable because of course
Dulles did operate at a high policy
level interviewing people who knew
Dulles or who had retired from the CIA
there were a large number of sources I
list them in the acknowledgments of
gentlemen spy and I think it goes over
two pages if I remember correctly a
large number of people were were happy
to help some of whom were willing most
of whom were willing to be named a few
still preferred not to have their names
used
many were credible to a large extent no
one was a hundred percent credible they
never are in in any kind of writing of
history you don't get 100% credibility
and precision this is the role of the
historian to make judgments to analyze
and the record is always alive and ready
to be corrected our next call Omaha
Nebraska on our line for Democrats hello
go ahead yes my name is Joyce Dutton my
husband was a CIC agent during the
second world war and I never hear it
talked about much I would like to say
that I was around the young man number
time they love to talk about their uh
when they had to write the reports to
Washington that seemed to be on their
minds a lot it was so important but what
I wanted to mention about a successful
operation my husband was stationed at
Alamogordo but there were planes being
brought down crashing during the Second
World War and they about a week they
halted all the planes flying out of
America and he along with one of the
engineers there on the base in
Alamogordo
I believe they probably El Paso he was
he went out there pasul discovered that
there was some sticky substance on the
outside of the motor and finally they
they figured out it had to do with using
either oil or gas from two different
companies and that's what caused that
crash so much was interesting though and
disturbing to me he was stationed then
in Tucson the same thing happened again
why wasn't that sent out immediately to
all the places that should have been
sent out to you've raised a very
important point about the nature of
intelligence the many levels of
information and assessment of that
information CIC of course was a Military
Intelligence Service Counter
Intelligence Corps
CIA and Allen Dulles was a civilian
service and the type of information
required or the the the the sought by
different intelligence services the type
of information is very different you
mentioned that interesting example about
the the oil on the surface of the plains
this is a fine example of highly
technical information which is extremely
important to certain people who are
tasked with dealing with that kind of
issue but frankly not at all important
to a Secretary of State or a president
of the United States except in its
possible implications intelligence is
very fragmented there are certain
agencies certain bureaus charged and we
have to include the FBI and this charged
with doing certain things with observing
certain things there are other agencies
Allen Dulles --is agency the CIA
foremost among them which operate on
more of a policy level and their mission
is to figure out what the leaders in the
Kremlin are going to do now in
caricature form or in Beijing or in
Tehran or in wherever these are policy
questions the answers are built up from
a whole range of other things but that
is the kind of issue that Allen Dulles
would be involved in as to why the
specific technical intelligence that you
mentioned was not widely disseminated
this is known as the the static factor
that so much information comes in this
was the problem at Pearl Harbor in 1941
long before so much Bitsey fragmentary
information comes in
it is a superhuman task to sort out
wheat from chaff to figure out how they
fit together and to draw a conclusion
from these little bits and pieces of
information which can be meaningful to a
political leadership which has to make a
decision Newark Delaware on our line for
others hello you're on with Peter gross
good morning gentlemen got a question
about Allen Dulles is posting in 1945 in
occupied Berlin and his oversight of the
white list of the compilation of those
untie his oversight of what the white
list okay and just dealing with those
people such as Carl blessing who
initially after the war Allen Dulles
helped to cultivate a kind of a story
that he was an anti-nazi when indeed it
turns out later that he was a part
member the Nazi party's early as 1937
and I just wanting as just a man like
Allen Dulles towards the end of his
career kind of looked back on things and
he made him thought at the time we're
right and it's you know at the end of
his career he may have said well you
know certain people or certain things I
did maybe weren't the right thing to do
or the right people to deal with as a
man like that have those kind of
thoughts or does he just look at the
time you know just figure that he did
what he had to do and no regrets don't
we all don't we all look back and say
gosh if I had known then what I know now
I wouldn't have done it that way but
then there are other people who just
shrugged their shoulders and say I did
the best I could at the time I did it
Harry Truman was one of those it doesn't
it there's no sense in in in beating
your breasts over mistakes that you made
when you made them at the time for the
best of reasons Allen Dulles --is work
in Germany after the war was indeed as
conflicted as you described
and there were quite a few people who
had been I let's say half a dozen or
more who had been Germans who had been
extremely helpful to the United States
intelligence service under the Nazi
regime a few of them may have been Nazi
Party members what do you do with a
person like this after the war
technically they had committed treason
against the government of the day it
happened to be Hitler's government and
there are many people who would say of
all governments to be to commit treason
against that's a pretty good candidate
nonetheless they had committed
treasonable acts so what do you do do
you try to do you ignore them do you
just dismiss them all saying they're
Nazis forget them do you ignore the
useful services that they performed
Allen Dulles did not he tried to help
individuals who some of whom may have
been quite worthy people others may have
been crass opportunists there are no
rules in this Dulles was very conflicted
about a number of these men he was not
at all conflicted about their families
their wives and and children and he used
every resource he could lay his hands on
to help those people in the difficult
years after the war reestablished their
lives mr. Ansari how many children did
uh Allen Dulles have Allen Dulles had
three children of two daughters and a
son uh none of whom were in any way
involved in his intelligence work he
kept his his life very carefully
compartmented his children did not know
what Dad was doing and his son Allen had
an incident a Korean War his son Alan
was a marine in the Korean War and
was uh was hit by mortar fire and
suffered a very serious concussion with
long lasting brain damage how did that
affect mr. Dulles he was you know
shattered and he what father couldn't be
and he's in his later years he he he and
clover his wife had great anguish in in
trying to find the the right kind of
medical and psychiatric treatment for
young Allen who is alive today West Palm
Beach Florida
go ahead please hi I was wondering
especially about the period in 1945 in
Germany whether Allen Dulles was aware
of Eisenhower's was aware and involved
in Eisenhower's policy of mass murder of
German war prisoners it's estimated 1
million may have perished in our in our
camps no I think there's a little bit of
a mix-up here of what you might be
referring to is the repatriation of
prisoners of war to Eastern Europe which
was agreed upon at Yalta as a gesture to
Stalin to the Soviet Union that any
Soviet citizens who were captured and
fell into allied camps at the during and
at the end of the war were to be
repatriated to the Red Army from whence
they came and this this was where
although the American government did not
understand it at the start this was
where these repetitive prisoners were
indeed executed by the communists the
American officers in the field were were
horrified as they saw what was happening
and they tried to stop the post in the
process and eventually it did stop but
too late for the many millions who
were repatriated by Franklin D Roosevelt
agreement with Joseph Stalin with tragic
consequences when did Allen Dulles leave
the CIA 1961 after the the failure of
the Bay Appiah Bay a pig aku Peaks
operation where a CIA force thought they
could overthrow Fidel Castro it was a
ghastly blunder with implications that
still remained Allen Dulles took the
blame for it all though he was by no
means the instigator it was on his watch
he took the blame and was very
graciously retired by President Kennedy
with whom he remained on very close
personal terms and for the next eight
years of his life he was a public figure
he wrote extensively he gave lectures
and then as I said he finally served as
a distinguished elder statesman on the
Warren Commission to investigate
Kennedy's assassination Conway South
Carolina is next go ahead please hi good
morning gentlemen
there are two points about the
intelligence community that I never hear
mentioned one is the connection that
Reverend moon of the unification Church
who owns the Washington Times the unite
for us international had strong
intelligence background with the CIA in
connections with the CIA since the 50s
or 60s and the other is that when Hanson
was first reported as a Russian spy in
91 by his brother-in-law to the FBI and
then in 92 he was reported by Russia to
President Bush he was they were informed
that he was a spy and yet the first
president Bush decided to keep him on
now when you connect it to the fact that
throughout the eight years of Clinton
Hansen was this FBI source that
reporters like Robert know
back and other people on the right used
to put in their articles some something
that it would implicate that FBI sources
have told me that they are looking at
this about Clinton or they're looking
like that about Janet Reno and yet this
is man was here to disrupt our
government and it and then surprisingly
right before right when george w bush
takes office he's captured and then is
he he's not given the death penalty
instead his wife is given his pension so
it seems to me that if you connect all
of these things it just doesn't bode
well for the Bush family and how they
control how you know what the public
hears caller thank you I I don't I can
confirm or deny the accuracy of anything
you've just said specifically about
Hanson or ever moon or anybody else what
I can say is this however you're dealing
in a very in a world of ambiguity with
large gray areas and information
intelligence like Henson was a Soviet
spy that Reverend moon worked for the
CIA the that information never comes
that specifically there are allegations
that a person may be up to no good these
allegations may be true or untrue Allen
Dulles himself used to say look I'm
dealing with useful people who for whom
I will not vote concerning every aspect
of their lives the people I deal with
are not Archbishop's a rather ironic
comment to be made today
uh he knew allen dulles appreciated the
moral gray areas I can tell you this
however that Alger Hiss who was as you
know on the center of great political
controversy in the early 1950s late 40s
and 50s we now know that President
Roosevelt was himself tipped off in 1944
that this young promising young diplomat
Alger Hiss may have been working too
closely with communist representatives
and Roosevelt ignored the information it
was it was one of the pieces of gossip
there was no proof there was no evidence
you get allegations all the time from
from over enthusiastic co-workers from
bureaucratic enemies from personal
enemies it it it's no good to say the
information was available in
such-and-such a day of 1919 whatever it
is why didn't we act on it it was too
obscure to be credible in many cases in
our last call this morning on this topic
is from New York City on our line for
Republicans go ahead yes good morning
c-span look we're talking my name is
Brian I'm from the in with section of
Manhattan we're talking about
infiltrators and spies I just want to
let c-span know Brian lamb I hope is
listening you have a screener that
answers the phone and in the last three
months or so I've called this my third
call the only time I got true this
screener did not ask me what my comment
was but there's a mail screener that you
have that asked me what my comment was
the first time and she thanks we'll pass
it along it was a conservative point of
view okay now that we got your chance to
talk to us be rolling out we're running
out of time once a question my question
is we know that during the 60s the peace
movement was infiltrated by communists
by Marxist and they basically led the
peace
within the 60s we know the drawing
Ronald Reagan's era that there were many
communist front groups that stood up for
Daniel Ortega in Nicaragua and we know
that people like Brian Becker and
earlier gentlemen to ask your guests
there
how how how serious is this these
implications of communists in these
so-called peace movements you know I'll
have to be quick I understand I would
make the same reaction to your question
that I did to the caricature of the CIA
as being all powerful and all capable I
think you are giving too much credit to
the expertise the skill of communist
infiltrators to think that they could
have engineered the holes peace movement
just as people give too much credit to
the CIA that they could have engineered
the Hungarian Revolution or whatever
Peter Gross is the author of gentleman
spy the life of Allen Dulles he has
several other books on the topic and
he's join us in our continuing series on
the history of US intelligence mr. gross
thank you Frank Hill I've enjoyed
talking with your guests coming up
tomorrow on Washington journal javea den
he is the assistant attorney general of
office of legal policy at the Justice
Department he will be discussing victims
rights we will be also joined in our
9:00 to 10:00 hour by Lincoln Kaplan
he's the editor and president of legal
affairs and David tell he is the opinion
editor of The Weekly Standard and they
will be participating in a roundtable
discussion of news for the day have a
good day we'll see you then